i was asked to speak at the war room
mastermind which is a thirty thousand
dollar year mastermind i think it's a
two or three hundred person program run
by ryan dice perry belcher and roland
fraser and it's a it's a great program
and i was asked to speak on sales i have
given versions of this sales
presentation a handful of times but this
is the best one that i think captured
the audio and the visual and everything
kind of put together and it's condensed
into a 30 minute video so i think you
guys will absolutely enjoy this so if
you're building your first sales script
if you're scaling a sales team and you
want to make sure that you can onboard
new people and get them selling at the
same percentage or better than you are
right now which for many people is
biggest bottleneck especially when
you're coming to for your first million
or first three million per year scaling
the sales team is one of the most
difficult tasks and so i've broken this
down into three frameworks that i've
used very successfully to scale lots of
different sales teams i say that the the
company i'm referencing in this video
has 14 that one company already now has
almost 30 sales guys so this process
continued to work past when i made this
presentation so if you're trying to
scale sales you want to close a higher
percentage you want to get more guys
closing at that same percentage or
better than yours and if you don't know
who i am my name is oxford mozzie on
acquisition.com we had a portfolio at
this moment of six companies to do 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you keep being awesome love you and
enjoy the video
what i'm going to be breaking down today
is the scripting process that we've
applied for calls right and so as the
world's worst marketer i sent my first
email this year i was very excited about
it we've been in business for 10 years
pretty big stuff and it was because i
couldn't get webinars i couldn't get
vsls i couldn't get all the fancy
stuff that you guys get to work um and
so i went back in time and just was like
if i can just get them to get my phone
number i'll be able to get them to like
buy [ __ ] from me and so i went and
called back all these webinar leads that
never showed up or never bought or
whatever and ended up doing like 100 000
in sales in a day and i was like wow
this is so much easier and so
over time i've consulted with sales
teams i've
trained and owned four high ticket
performance teams i think we have
12 or 14 sales guys now it kind of
rotates and so what i want to do is kind
of show you what we've done to
consistently replicate the skill of
sales another human being would that be
cool all right so if i can add like 10
to your conversion rate in terms of how
you attract better closers how you
script the process out and how you
should close more deals and scale them
to incentivize them would that be
valuable for you guys
all right sweet so these are the three
frameworks that transform losing funnels
into cash machines that was my real life
that was a picture of my actual first
funnel and that's what it became and so
these are the three fails uh the
frameworks number one closer framework
how to ask questions to get prospects to
say yes adding this to a funnel
instantly can make it profitable all
right this is my personal experience
number two is a conviction framework all
right how anyone who believes can
outperform a seasoned sales rep by
simply learning control their tone
really important that's one of the
biggest things that most sales people
miss
number three the scaling framework how
to easily duplicate this process across
sales people in any niche in seven days
or less so seven days from now we can do
this would that be cool
all right let's rock so number one the
closer framework
after going through hundreds of scripts
i've bought grand stuff about the wolf
of wall street stuff i bought all that
stuff and going through my own sales
processes i learned that the the
scripting process even was simpler i
think
than it's portrayed it's not that it's
something to be sold against but um
every sales script that has been
absolutely gangbusters has been a
question-based framework that is based
on this process all right and this works
for b2c sales works for b2b uh b2b sales
it works for 500 tickets it works for
100 000 tickets the process is the same
and so this is the acronym closer
framework as i said world's dumbest
marketer so i made it nice and easy to
remember all right so c
clarify why they're there when i look at
creating a script the first thing we ask
is like why the hell are you here what
made you reach out to us today what was
the thing what is the goal you're trying
to accomplish right
two label them with a problem we can't
cure cancer unless they admit that they
have it right has anyone had a situation
like i just want to find out more
information you ever had that
right it's like well i'm assuming you're
not hopping on sales calls all day just
running for find information is there a
problem you're trying to solve
oh you're fat got it all right boom so
yeah that's a problem we can solve it
after that i'm sure i'm assuming i'm not
the first guy you've ever dated right so
is there anything else that you've had
happen in the past that got you here
that didn't work i'd love to know more
about it s once we've gone through the
pain we saw on the vacation right
there's a process that i'll walk through
e we explain away their concerns because
obviously same people don't make
decisions on the first call
unless you're a closer in which case
they do
which i'll talk about and then finally
and this is something that we actually
added in my original framework for my
first couple of years was closed
and then we added the r
because when you do this it actually
transitions into the onboarding process
that will get higher ltv per customer
lower churn lower refunds or chargebacks
which are sales guys and you will be
happy about cool
all right let's rock so we'll examine
each one more closely clarify why
they're there these are the questions
that sounds like what made you come in
today what made you reach out what's
your goal right now why is that
important to you why that number
specifically what does that what does it
resonate for you right why is that real
l the questions that we're looking is
like okay so what i'm hearing is
xyz usually does that sound about right
right really simple but very important
it's a milestone that has to be hit in
the process all right then we overview
all right this is where we're gathering
all the intel and for some of you guys
my goal is that you can take this to
your sales team or sales director and
run your script through this framework
and then see where you can plug it you
probably have some of it but if you're
missing one or two of these questions
milestones you're losing conversions on
the call like you're closing people who
already had those obstacles covered
but everyone who didn't have two of
these questions covered you lose them
and you don't know why you watch the
sales call you're like what the hell
happened here right so
what have you tried so far to accomplish
that how this is what we call the pain
cycle it's a four-step process what have
you tried so far to accomplish this how
long did you do that for how long ago
had that worked for you what else have
you tried right so we just do that cycle
until they're like
well yeah that's it now that you think
about it i've tried everything under the
sun like i can't imagine what that's
felt like
wow
right it's not your fault
you're so close you're six inches away
right and i think you've said this one
thing which i'm about to show you in a
second we could be able to help you want
to hear about the program
fantastic that's when we transition to
sale right so sell them a vacation the
number one thing that people mess up our
sales pitch on the call is under three
minutes
three minutes 180 seconds
when we talk about um i think someone
was asking about what are the bullets on
the page
we don't say anything about that because
what we're trying to do is get them to
understand what they're going to
experience not how they're going to
experience it
right and so when we have a sales pitch
just about every time we sell three
things right and it doesn't matter what
industry and i was training a mortgage
leads team and they were selling leads
right it was like uh the leads are
exclusive they're timely and they're
qualified right so we talked about hey
you've had leads in the past ah well the
zillow leads my real estate people right
the zillow leads are not they are timely
but they're definitely not exclusive
these are people just window shopping
right our leads are different three
things you can always find them you're
selling fitness you're selling fitness
nutrition accountability right and so
what we do is when we say the three
bullets
get them to understand yes that takes
five seconds cool fitness wise we get
the commitment this is what i need you
to do fair enough to be like i need to
work out three days a week can you do
that awesome if we see any hesitation
you have a 30 second story that's
memorized most of this script and this
is what makes it scalable is a
question-based framework which means if
you get lost you can find your way back
again if anybody here have scripts that
are like paragraphs and stuff anyone
okay like no no one has a script that's
paragraphs and pages
please
we all know
um
but if you have those things it'll
totally mess it up because then the
sales guy gets lost and then he's just
free balling and he has no idea where he
is hot dog in the hallway no idea what's
going on right and so the point is here
a little visual anyways
is that when we're telling the story
like with the fitness example i would
say hey when you failed in the past
like right now do you have a do you have
a favorite tv show
game of thrones that's awesome do you
feel like like you gotta get motivated
watch game of thrones you're like oh man
i've been wanting to watch it but i just
can't get up the motivation to watch tv
they're like well no i don't have that
it's like right and so that's exactly
how we're going to make your fitness
program so if you look forward to you
don't need the motivation the willpower
because that's why you failed in the
past
they're like oh
i didn't talk about the workouts the
heart rate and the calories they're
going to burn and they're going to sweat
because all that [ __ ] sounds like work
right but what they do get is exactly
what they want which is wait so you're
telling me that if i actually like
something
i'm not going to even have to try and
it's going to feel like watching tv
because i look forward to it it's
exactly what i'm saying and if you can
deliver you make tons of money and
that's the point so each of those points
your sales guys should know
what that anecdotal story is
right if i was selling accountability
anywhere of kids
anyone here tell their kids to brush
their teeth
and we have their kids who brush their
teeth say they don't want to brush their
teeth
anyone tell their kids even though they
want to brush their teeth to brush their
teeth anyways
and now you're an adult did your parents
do that to you
do you brush your teeth that's an
example of external accountability
turning into an internal habit that's
exactly what the accountability we're
going to do in this program industries
that make sense
great
done next bullet that's how you
transition the pitch right so if you
think about this process why are you
here i have cancer i think we might be
able to help you out but i don't want to
get into that because i don't know about
you like i don't know what your
situation is tell me what you've done ah
that sounds that sounds great that makes
sense
okay
i think we might be able to see a little
bit about that all it is i tell three
stories that make complete sense to
everything you just told me
and then we transitioned and so um i
pretty much just covered this
um but we call it selling the vacation
out to plane flight right and so we're
not selling csa we're not selling your
modules your meal plan your macros you
work out your support team your urls
your whatever
right we're selling maui we're selling
the final destination and it doesn't
matter what level of service you are
selling you're always selling the same
thing it's always maui it's just how do
you want to get there do you want to
swim to maui right
do you want to take a boat to maui do
you want to take a normal flight or do
you want to take a private jet to maui
right it's your call you're getting them
out either way because we're a man of
our word i'm not going to sell you
something that's not going to deliver
right but it's going to be a little
different a little bit rockier but we're
going to get you there all right so
everyone gets to maui the variables are
the squeak the speed and the quality of
the journey all right the likelihood of
arrival is assumed
so since it's always the same thing
you probably have multiple levels of
business um but it's always the same
process right and so once we have that
they're like got it
and then we just make the ask all right
from this point going forward it's
explaining away their concerns like any
human being would normally do i could
drill price over comes with you but i
think it's more valuable to explain the
thought process behind
price
stall
and decision maker
objections all right so the first and
obvious one is i can't afford it anyone
get this one right a couple people
two people have gotten this
you guys have the best leads
give me your leads uh and so the easy
question that i use to explain to our
sales team because it's really about
breaking their lease beliefs is if we
were giving away ferraris right now for
five grand
do you think they'd find a way to get
the money
yes
so that simply they do not understand
the value we're trying to provide and if
you can get your team to believe that
then they understand that it is always
their fault
if someone cannot afford the program
does that make sense
fantastic
second decision maker close one of the
hardest things to overcome right i gotta
have my business partner i gotta have my
husband my spouse my whatever right
so we give a specific process that we go
about this
and so what we do is in the very
beginning we just say
we circumvent
then we go over past agreements and then
we ask for forgiveness all right this is
the best way that i've seen to overcome
this so the first thing we say is well
what if they say no one out of three
times they'll be like i'll probably do
it anyways we're like let's get started
boom it's done you'd be amazed how many
times that actually works it's hilarious
if they say well then i wouldn't do it
then we divert we say
well what do you think their biggest
objection would be about it because now
they're just using a foil you know the
person's not there and it's no idea what
the program is because they're not
involved with the call right they're
like well i think this and at this point
we can attack the actual obstacle even
though the decision maker isn't there
now if they still if we still can't
overcome it then we go to past
agreements we say well does your
business partner know you guys are
struggling on sales well yeah
does he approve of that
well no then why would he be against
something that he already doesn't
approve of that doesn't make any sense
why would he be a business partner
solving a problem you know what you do
well it's great you're being a great
partner let's go right and so we try and
rely on past agreements that are obvious
and use those to project into the
present right
and then finally you know sometimes it's
better ask for uh forgiveness and
permission right
and so we'll tack that on again you can
put that at the end of any of the closes
and so when we're dealing with this with
price it's value
with decision maker we go on past
agreements and with stalls we just teach
people to make decisions
people just so afraid of making the
wrong decision they're petrified and so
we do is we literally teach them on the
call here's how you make a decision
these are the variables you should be
considering x y and z right can the
product meet your needs do you think
that if you work with us you have a
greater or lower likelihood of losing
weight
greater fantastic i think we're halfway
there do you want to work with us do you
think it'd be fun to hang out and see me
everyday because believe me this stash i
had i had to work 12 months to get my
wife to say yes to that so i understand
if you're hesitant does that make sense
would you be willing to do that all
right let's rock right and then do you
have access to funds or know someone who
does right it's not just about you
because if it's something that's amazing
we can find other ways to finance this
so do you have access or know someone
who does
yes
well then great
let's get started and if for some reason
we haven't closed them at this point we
say how about this let's take a card
down we'll delay the payment to friday
you go to your husband go to your
business partner right you go to your i
love this one you go to your husband
right and he says
baby
i want you to live a shorter life i want
you to i want you to be a terrible
example to our kids i want you to not
have generational health in our family
to be passed down i want you to sit in
that corner i want you to pull those
sweatpants up take up a bag of cheetos
rub your fingers on there right and just
get comfortable with the fact that
you're never going to look better than
you are right now it's like if your
husband says that to you you call me
back and i will tear this contract up
fair enough
right
you close them all right so we explain
away their concerns and then finally we
get the yes we reinforce the decision
this is stuff that we started doing it
helped a lot so personalized video from
the ceo hey welcome aboard so happy to
have you thank you for trusting us with
your business hey we're so happy to have
you thank you for touching with your
weight loss journey and our personal
licenses we're going to do everything in
our power to absolutely amaze you right
little things like that because the
customer is usually deciding whether or
not they like your business in the first
48 hours after the sale i learned this
later so how you hand off from sale to
customer experience and activation is
where this all happens does that make
sense
is that cool was that nice framework to
work through okay so that's the
disclosure framework that is the first
thing that's what you can run your
script through all right how to ask the
questions to get the prospects to say
yes
check
one down two to go you with me you're
still good
all right let's rock so conviction
framework number two how anyone who
believes can outperform a season sales
rep by simply learning to control their
tone all right so um after i reworked
all of our scripts using the closer
framework um some of my guys were really
successful but other ones still blew and
i was like well this sucks right i was
really excited i had a little acronym
and everything i was like that took me a
long time to come with the acronym right
and i was like what gives
and so
i talked to my friends
um and they recommended this book which
was awesome and the biggest takeaway
from this book is that is the concept of
tone and this was something that really
helped take us and give an extra edge
for our sales training ourselves process
and the coaching that we give people
right
and so in the book he talked about the
hidden dialogue
which i just love and i just never want
to take credit for an idea because i got
it from him but there's two dialogues
that are happening right
because the words are the logic right
what you're actually saying is talking
the logical brain
how you say it is talking to the
emotional brain right that's the one's
making decision that's the one running
the shot all right and so how you say
what you say
is what you say
so here's an example
that's my wife she's going to be here
with me soon but
if she were here if she said
alex
right or alex
right or alex
very different meanings
very different afternoon for me
in each of these scenarios right
based on how she said it because there's
so much communicated and that's just one
word
imagine a 30-minute dialogue where each
word can be chosen to have packed with
the meaning that you need them to feel
does that make sense
okay
so we need the words for the logical
influence we need the tone for the
emotional influence we need both okay
and so once you become a more seasoned
like sales prep you can learn to control
your tone on purpose right you can raise
your voice at the end of the statement
to make it into a question
right
it's a question
this is john
right i didn't need to ask him i'm
saying
you know to answer that as a question i
didn't ask you that but you know that
based on the tone right
or i could lower my voice right now see
that what i'm saying extremely
important right tone matters
and so it takes time to develop this
level of unconscious mastery so there's
two ways to develop this
and i believe that you can either trick
yourself into it or you can train
yourself into it
and since i don't have enough time in 30
minutes to train on the influence of
tonalities here's the trick is that all
right let's give you the hack
conviction will correct your tone
if you believe in what you sell
you will say it the right way
and that's why some of you guys have a
sales rep who comes on crushes it and
then tanks
because they did believe and then they
saw your reviews or they got customer
support feedback or someone called them
up after buying it was like [ __ ] you i
can't believe you did that
and they're done
and then all their tone's off because
they feel like out of ethics right and
so i'm lowering my tone right now so you
know that this is really important
right
and so i'll go upbeat kiss the boo-boo
bring us back up all right and so real
estate sales team consulting this is a
great story so i was flown out
paid way more money than i should have
been paid um to fly out and consult with
the sales team all right they were
selling mortgage leads the example i was
given earlier
and they were really excited they wanted
me to give this abc always be closing
chat like this huge pump up chat so i
spent the first half the day on the
script and the second half of the day
was supposed to be drilling the sales
team right so i get on the sales team
they got they had a nine person sales
floor
and uh they're like we're having some
problems with this guy john i was like
alright cool
so i was like john
how good are the leads
he was like
well you know there's kind of and i was
like i'm good thank you and i was like
because if you [ __ ] thought the leads
were good you would say dude they're
unreal i can't believe it right now i'm
getting my mom to pass her real estate
certification so i can start sending her
leads i'm studying for mine i'm a couple
months behind but i'm telling you as
soon as i [ __ ] get this thing passed
i'm out of here i'm gonna start buying
these leads myself cause i'll make more
than i make right now sales guy that's
what you'd say if you believed
right the way you say and what you'd say
would be entirely different it's one of
the hacks on this by the way has anyone
ever gotten hot or has a sales guy got
hot
start just closing closing close it
close it anyone
that becomes the sales training for that
person
because the way they ask the question at
what point how they closed
that's how it's perfect and so they
should study the best game footage when
they're on a streak
and that's when you can replicate it
much more easily because it's like in
the wild you'll witness it and that's
when they're masters right in those
moments all right and so these are the
actions that we do so i'm transitioning
into tactics for you guys who have teams
all right
re-read the testimonials out loud daily
in front of your sales team
if you got fresh ones which you should
read them it makes their day makes them
feel like they're making impact right
they're getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
them every single day getting hung up on
getting cussed at getting told to [ __ ]
off every day right and like the best
thing you can do is give him a cup of
coffee and says hey man you're [ __ ]
doing good in the world right so they
need so do it every day number two fix
everything you can about the product
this is obvious
but i want to say it directly like don't
blame the customer for a lack of success
because it doesn't help anyone right
doesn't help them doesn't help us if we
can take ownership then we can fix the
product right
three never stop improving it so you
always know it's up to date and this is
a good one for the sales team if your
sales dip
take your head of customer support
bring them to the sales meeting
and say erica tell these guys what you
do for our customers they're like oh
well the first day what we do is we send
this text and we send them this letter
and then we give them swag and then we
follow up with them and then we like
write them a handwritten card and leave
them a back massage and a foot massage
and then we find a wife for them it's
unbelievable you know what i mean and
then the sales guys are like god this is
[ __ ] awesome i'm like i know let's go
sell it right and so these are the
actions that you can do on a daily basis
to get your team to be excellent all
right and so that's how you can hack
conviction and get your team's tone
unconsciously correct by just truly
believing the product
is that cool you think you'd sell more
if you did that
sweet thank you
all right
conviction framework number two check
all right number three scaling framework
how to easily duplicate this process
across sales people in any niche in
seven days or less all right so we've
talked about closing framework we've
talked about conviction framework and
this is the oops i think i'm going to
skip one oh no we are back great so when
i showed my sales team to stuff they
didn't do it every time all right
because you're probably going to come
back from here all gung-ho you might
show them this video they're like yeah
they go rah-rah for two to three days
and then it's like back to normal right
no one wants that
so piece by piece we implemented
processes to get the same outcome over
and over and over again because of the
110 million dollars we've sold which is
crazy it's been 100 over the phone
no one over the age of 20
no we got one guys 40. but beyond
besides him everyone's younger than 27
27 27 years old all right like these
aren't like crazy you know i mean like
crazy veterans right you just do this
process over and over again and get the
right thing
as a total aside
find people and educate them about your
prospect
not your
product because that's a big [ __ ] up
because like they shouldn't even be
talking that much about the product they
should be knowing everything about the
prospect and so right now if your sales
training is focused on your product
you're doing it wrong these are the six
c's that i use to scale teams from
little guy to lots of guys all right
so this delta you know we used this to
build a 3000 person affiliate base in
our physical products company it added
35 million in sales
which is cool which is awesome and so i
will show you how this works all right
and so um we've used these sales teams
and this is how we've kind of these are
all multi-figure teams and i'll show you
what we did all right so closer sequence
is the first c which we went over
earlier
the second c is consistent daily
training and conviction and i'll show
you how to do each of these call
recordings you got to record them
communication cycles cuts and
competition there's the six c's all
right
so number one make sure you have a
question based framework that follows
those steps in the script it should just
be questions it's so much easier to just
follow questions because if someone's
out and you know out in left field you
know wandering like onto the highway
you're like whoa hey come back over here
this is the next question in this
process so thank you so much for sharing
that that must have been so hard for you
so what do you think that brought you
right they should go right in the next
question the sale all right
number two
uh consistent daily training this is the
number one thing if you take one thing
away from this besides conviction
because that'll do more for yourselves
than anything this is the second biggest
thing all right is that daily training
our team training 60 minutes a day five
days a week we actually do twice a day
stuff but that's okay anyways for right
now if you just do this you'll already
be way better than everyone else in your
market all right so we do talking and
listening because the sales person needs
to know how to speak
the right tone
you know to listen right so we draw both
scales
for talking we have them read the script
out loud and the questions with the
correct tonality
for 25 minutes and if they [ __ ] up they
start again
simple
five minutes we drill obstacle overcomes
i need to think about it i'm not sure
i don't have the money can't afford that
right now i gotta talk to my partner
right i know what's gonna work in my
market or whatever your specific
obstacles are because those when they're
in the red zone they shouldn't have to
think about those so the only two things
that someone will ever truly memorize
will be those 30 second anecdotal
stories i mentioned earlier
and your optical overcomes it makes it
much easier to get new people on the
team
listening so every day we'll listen to a
30-minute recording and we'll go with
what went right in this call
what went wrong
what do you do next time
very simple right you play the call
everyone watches it's game tape review
we're like man you got kicked in the
balls on this one right
but you had great rapport in the first
five minutes
right
um you're like what went wrong and that
was about it
um and what you gonna do next time i'm
gonna transition from the report of the
question asking without sounding like a
douchebag fantastic all right next day
and you continue to improve
i know this sounds crazy simple but it's
so simple no one will do it
so number three sees is call recordings
if you don't call like record your calls
one you're not compliant but two like
how are you gonna study game film you
know i mean everybody's got all their
data and you've got your mouse tracking
on all the pages i'm like where's the
mouse tracking on the calls
right that's where that's we're gonna
train your team this is like every nba
team they play the game and they watch
the game footage right why are we not
doing that with the sales team and so
you should have to record it if you use
zoom gong is absolutely the best highly
recommend it it's been awesome users for
two years they'll tell you exactly how
many minutes people are talking versus
someone else they'll tell you who's
talking the most where how many
questions were asked if the ai they have
there is unbelievable um it's expensive
but it's worth it
four calm cycles and feedback um
i don't know if you guys heard the story
but if i were trying to uh fix your golf
swing right and i said okay
so i take a swing looking like i do like
a like an idiot right he's like all
right man well first off lose 40 pounds
so you can rotate all right after you do
that uh change your wrist by two degrees
turn your other hand over put your thumb
underneath i need you to take your first
foot put it forward and then point it
the other way and then put this foot
back and try again
i'm [ __ ] no chance of swinging right
but if he just said hey
take another 20 swins and just put one
thumb under the other one
i'd have one thing to work on and i
could probably get better and so when
you're training and this is for the
sales directors if you're helping them
out with that call what what when right
went wrong
that what am i going to do about it is
the one thing
does that make sense and so in terms of
communication cycles
we do weekly with the team
we've got daily training
we've got daily wrap-up at the end which
is really just to pump up and kiss them
on the forehead good night to make sure
they feel okay right because they do get
punched in the face all day so it's
worth being like hey you see derek's
overcome this morning is [ __ ] awesome
he killed it let's watch that as like
highlight footage like watch him say
he's gonna have to talk to his wife
overcome right and then and then they're
like dude you killed it and then it just
makes them feel like they're part of the
team right and so that's where we do the
feedback and the communication cycles
and then we do once once a week if
they're new we'll do one-on-ones if
they're a little bit older we'll do once
every other week
does that make sense can you use this
right now what i'm giving you for your
sales teams
okay sweet
number five cut the fat cut it fast
um
randy probably knows this better than
anyone
when you hire salespeople at least in my
experience
like
it's sink or swim like if guys if guys
can't close in the first week to two
weeks unless it's some sort of crazy
complex thing they ain't closing right
and then i've got somebody who now came
in neutral now they feel like they suck
right they're actually worse than
someone who's new because now i gotta
overcome all your beliefs and then bring
you back up and so in my experience it's
been much easier to take a six and get
into a nine than try and take then try
and take a two and get him to a five
it's more work and it's not good for me
or him right does that make sense so in
most cases does anyone have a sales
person that you've been waiting for them
to turn the corner for the last like six
months
they're not going to turn the corner
unless they have like a come to jesus
moment which does happen but it doesn't
need to happen on my team you can do
that and come back right all right
number six competition and career path
all right
it's a big one so sales people are
competitive right as they should be
right they are hunters and they should
go hunt and so having competition on
regular basis what we have found is that
six weeks cycles tends to work best it
is long enough that they believe they
can accomplish something but short
enough they believe it's going to happen
soon and so we run our competitions on
six week cycles
for us i think what you said uh whatever
ryan said about the percentages 10 to 15
percent actually works pretty well as
like a group goal um when we have those
as like top sales person would like we
did like weekend to vegas so we'll split
all the guys that way like four teams of
four you know what i mean they're all
comp so it's like you get the
competitiveness but you still get the
camaraderie because if it's just one you
know one versus everyone sometimes they
can get um a little bit too you know
teethy uh and so having like little mini
teams helps too because then you can you
can kind of like make it an adjusted
draft you put the best guy with the
worst guy and then he helps him out and
he speeds him up does that make sense
and then career path this is one that i
probably learned later but it's really
good
is that
you can have minor minor
road uh milestones like 50 deals closed
100 deals closed 150 deals closed right
and they just get a little just a little
you know they go from 500 a deal to 525
a deal right they go from 525 to 550
deal just the fact that there's this
this road map of where they're going and
there's actual progress because sales is
one of the most repetitive positions in
the world
just the fact that they're doing this
and they're something is changing on the
outside i think just helps relieve
anxiety and help the guys focus so that
is one of the things that i would
recommend doing um with the career path
and then obviously if you have roles
like depending how big your team is
manager etc and you can move up
something that i don't have on here that
i will add is that
this seems to be common practice but
remember dumbest marketer on earth
outbound and inbound
uh keep them separated we also have
setters and closers for both of those
teams so outbound sets are different
than inbound sets
which go to different ink closers on
either side right because the prospects
are a little bit different right and so
if you if you have lots of different
types of leads going to the same person
you're probably losing a lot of
efficiency if you don't have that much
lead flow that's another issue but
it's as soon as you can separating them
out will get you a lot a lot higher
conversion rates
all right so i'll recap this the 60s for
scaling our closer sequence make sure
that's in a question-based framework
daily trainings and convictions so
you're reading the testimony every day
you're training them every morning on
talking listing the most valuable skills
that a salesman can have call recordings
to make sure that they're actually doing
a gamete footage to actually look at
communication cycles to actually improve
on their skills based on the game
footage that we just had
you cut the bottom people who are just
dragging the team down that probably
just don't have the makeup for this and
then you keep it competitive and you
give them a career path so they have
something to look forward to in the
future all right and so uh now you can
understand how anyone can sell expensive
flat paper pro even if you don't think
you're any good
which is completely normal
yeah that sales